متى يرفعون السكاكين على بعضهم البعض لا
يمكن تصور او قد لا يتصور كثيرون ان هذه
الحكومه ستستمر طويلا على هذا النسق وانما
مالها في نهايه المطاف الى التفكك والذهاب
الى انتخابات مبكره او شيء من هذا القبيل
متى نعم تحياتي محمود واستاذ محمود
ولضيوفك الكرام اي بطبيعه الحال هنا يجب
ان نتذكر ان الحديث هنا تحديدا عن مثلث
نحن نتحدث عن مثلث لديه ثلاثه اركان هذه
الحرب مثلث من ثلاثه اضلاع تحديدا الضلع
الاول هو شخص بنيامين نتنياهو الضلع
الثاني الميدان والضلع الثالث هو
الكابينيت او هذه الحكومه بالمجمل في كل
ما يخص الميدان صوره الارباك واضحه للعلن
ربما هنالك الحديث بالذات في الايام
الاخيره عن صوره ارباك لم تشدها اسرائيل
من قبل 12 1500 معاق حتى هذه اللحظه اكثر
من 500 قتيل الجرحى بالالاف صوره لم تكن
تتوقعها اسرائيل باعتقادي بمفهوم كهذا او
كاخر ولا تستطيع حتى هذه اللحظه طريقه
تسويقها الى العلن يعني و ولا يوجد يعني
الحديث حتى عن العتاد هو هامشيا بات في ظل
هذه الارقام هذه النقطه الاولى في الجانب
الثاني لربما هو كذلك يجب ان ناخذه
بالاعتبار شخص بنيامين نتنياهو المحاكم لم
تكن لتحت دم مع بنيامين نتنياهو ما قبل
السابع من اكتوبر كما تفعل ال اليوم
بنيامين نتنياهو كان يعرف كيف يتغذى من
هذا العراق ما بينهما بين مع محكمه القضاء
العليا في داخل اسرائيل بل على العكس من
ذلك هو اراد من المحكمه ان تهاجمه بشكل
شخصي لكي يقلص من شرعيتها امام الشارع
اليميني وبالتالي كل القضايا التي سوف تبت
بها المحكمه اتجاه بنيامين نتنياهو سوف
تكون شخصيه في المقام الاول هذا ما اراده
بنيامين نتنياهو هذا المشهد كان صحيحا ما
قبل السابع من اكتوبر ما بعد السابع من
اكتوبر القاعده الشعبيه لبنيامين نتنياهو
اختلفت فبالتالي نرى تراكم المشاهد هم
يرونه الان كقصه ضعيفه يهجمون عليها بدون
اي يعني اي تردد اصلا هذا الامر تسرب
المشهدين الاثنين تسربا وتشرب منهما
الكابينيت ومجلس الحرب والحكومه والائتلاف
الضلع الثالث في نهايه المطاف انا
باعتقادي ان لولا يعني لو كانت الصوره في
الميدان مختلفه ولو كانت صوره بنيامين
نتنياهو كذلك مختلفه لما تجرا هذا
الكابينيت على القيام بكل ما يقوم به في
هذه المرحله التصرفات في داخل الكابينيت
توحي بانها تصرفات نهايه الحرب عندما يقوم
رئيس هيئه الاركان ويطالب او يقوم بتشكيل
لجنه تحقيق بكل ما يخص فشل الجيش تحديدا
دون غيره بعيده عن كل الاشكاليات المهنيه
التقنيه وحتى السياسيه اذا اردنا ان نتحدث
عن ذلك في كل هذه اللجنه بعيده عن كل ذلك
هي اشارات واضحه جدا للشارع الاسرائيلي
بان هنالك حاله من عدم الثقه ما بين كل
هذه المركبات وعندما يخرج جانس يدعم هذه
رئيس هيئه الاركان عندما يخرج جانس
وبالذات الان في ظل الاستطلاعات التي لا
تبشر له بخير وهذه النقطه مهمه جدا في
نهايه المطاف جانس اراد ان يستفيد من
دخوله الى مجلس الحرب انتخابيا ما اراده
بنيامين نتنياهو هو ان يسحب جانس معه في
داخل الرمال المتحركه في داخل غزه اذا فشل
بنيامين نتنياهو فليفل الجميع وعلى ما
يبدو انه صدق في ذلك الاستطلاعات الاخيره
تشير الى فقدانه بضعه من المقاعد في
الانتخابات المقبله فبالتالي كل هذه
الاشكاليه بدات تحرك جميع الاركان في
مفهوم كهذا او كاخر وربما هذا ياخذنا الى
اشاره مهمه جدا كذلك بالتالي على ما يبدو
ان الاداره الامريكيه لم تكن تمزح حينما
قالت ان بدايه 2024 هو الخط الاحمر